[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without him hello
everyone welcome to a special edition of
hashtag ask the minimalist live my name
is Joshua fields Milburn I am riding
solo today it's because I'm supposed to
be in Florida right now with Ryan we
have a coffee shop down there called
bandit Coffee Co and my plane got
canceled yesterday and so I'm stuck here
in so sunny no way it's not sunny as he
is it it's snowy snowy Montana sorry I
was thinking forward to a sunny st.
Petersburg Florida but that's alright so
I'm here and I'm so low but I'm gonna
answer some of your questions today and
so let's see here
Ryan and I just had a documentary come
out it's called minimalism a documentary
about the important things and it came
out this summer in theatres a hit on
line later this summer and now it is
available on Netflix finally so we're
finally on Netflix and so we've had
hundreds of thousands of people watching
it on Netflix so some of you might have
questions about the documentary if you
can't find it in your country you can
always find it on Vimeo it's available
worldwide on Vimeo and so I'd love to
answer some questions for you Sean
I've got podcast Sean here with me right
now he's monitoring this this is the
first time we've ever used YouTube live
by the way I don't see any questions on
my screen which is either a good thing
or a bad thing I don't know so let me
refresh what I've got here and we'll see
if anyone has any questions do you see a
video of me at all anywhere I've got
people watching me it says says there
there are our eyeballs aggregated onto
the the screen so I could pontificate
for a few minutes do you see anywhere
where there are questions or is anyone
making comments here yes
is sweet here's how we're gonna do it
then so we have podcast Shawn here he's
going to throw out the questions that he
finds to be the most relevant you'll
hear his deep baritone voice in the
background we typically don't give Shana
a microphone by the way because he's
much more intelligent than us and he
would make us sound far dumber than we
are and so yeah we we're gonna handle it
this way he'll throw out some questions
I will answer them impromptu this sort
of extemporaneous exchange between you
and i and maybe will answer questions
until my water is gone what do we got
Shawn hello hello are you planning on
making another movie in the future my
answer to that is I don't know I think
those are three of the most powerful
words in the English language by the way
just saying I don't know abdicate to you
not completely from your
responsibilities but from having to know
everything now I will tell you this so
Ryan and I six years ago this month we
started the minimalists calm and that
journey started before that even you as
I had simplified my life back in 2009 my
my mother died and my marriage ended
both in the same month and those two
events really forced me to look around
and start to question what had become my
life's focus and I realized I was so
focused on on the wrong stuff right and
I forsook the things that were most
important to me and I embarked on this
journey of minimalism where I I started
letting go of the excess stuff in my
life mainly so I could start focusing on
what was truly important to me and
figuring out what was important to me so
my health my relationships passion
contribution growth these are the the
core values that I uncovered after
letting go of the excess stuff in my
life and I people were at work started
coming to me and saying you seemed so
much less stress you seemed so much
calmer and you seemed happier is what my
best friend guy named Ryan Nicodemus he
came up to me and he said you seem
happier and it's not that my life was
perfect it was far from perfect it
wasn't stress free or free of anxiety it
was just improving my overall situation
let
go of the more trite vapid problems and
improving the problems I had in in my
own life and so by letting go of the
excess stuff people around me started
noticing the the benefits of minimalism
the benefits of simplifying in my life
because I never jumped up and said look
at me I'm becoming a minimalist and you
should too because all of you you have
so much crap and I'm judging you know
even now Ryan and I are going out
proselytizing I don't want to convert
anyone to minimalism that's not the idea
here what we're trying to do is share a
recipe that's worked really well for me
and a slightly different recipe that's
worked really well for Ryan and that's
what we've really done over the last six
years so when we first started the
minimalists com it was because Ryan was
like hey I've been journaling about my
whole process of simplifying after he
had he had found out about minimalism
from me and he did this crazy thing
called a packing party for those of you
who aren't familiar check out his TEDx
talk that he did you can just go to our
YouTube page there youtube.com slash the
minimalists we have two TEDx talks there
I did one and he did all the background
theatrics that one was this year and
then a couple years ago he did one
called a rich life with a less and in
that TEDx talk he talks about this
packing party where he boxed up
everything that he owns literally
pretended like he was moving so he had
this huge 2,000 square foot condo and
everything he owned he boxed up as if he
were moving so even his furniture his
electronics his toiletries his clothes
his kitchen utensils everything that he
owned pretending he was moving and over
the course of about three weeks he
unboxed only the items he needed and he
learned some pretty important lessons
throughout that process mainly at the
end of this three week process 80% of
his stuff was still in boxes and you're
like I can't even remember what's in
most of these boxes I worked so hard
over the last decade to accumulate all
these things to make me happy but those
things aren't doing their job and so he
decided to let go of all of it and
through that process he was journaling
and about a month later he came to me
this was the fall of 2010 he said you
know I think other people could find
value from from this journey I found
value from your story Josh and
and I think other people would find
value from our story and so you you've
been talking about these different
websites out there that led you toward
minimalism maybe we could share our
story as well and so that's where the
minimalists com started was with that
21-day journey that packing party and
the lessons learned from that really and
and and from that process what we
learned is you know what people are
getting value from this so I kept
writing more and more about it you see
throughout my 20s I wanted to write
literary fiction that was really my my
passion the thing that I wanted to do I
wanted to write books and so this is a
very secure this answer to to answer
their the question but I'm getting there
I promise so I wanted that I wanted to
write books mostly right and then we
started blogging in fact we didn't even
know it was called a blog at the time we
just started writing these essays online
putting him up online at our on our
website and people started getting value
from that I started sharing it with
their friends and family in that first
month we had 52 people visit our website
which was really great but it was only
great because I spent most of my 20s
getting rejection letters from people
agents and publishers telling me no no
no no no and now people were finally
saying yes to what I was what I was
creating at least a few dozen people
were but the cool thing about that is
when you find value in something I don't
know know about you but when I find
value in something I tend to share it
with the people I care about so a blog
posts or a movie or a TEDx talk or a
podcast episode if I enjoy something
I'll share what the people I care about
hoping they get the same kind of value
that I got from the thing and so over
the last six years we found different
vehicles to add value to people's lives
this is getting back to answer your
question you needed some context first
and so we wrote our first book in 2011
it's called minimalism live a meaningful
life and people found value in that and
then Ryan and I moved out to Montana
four years ago wrote our second book
called everything that remains it was a
memoir about the last four years of our
lives and so that was a different
vehicle to share our message but then we
also went out on tour we've been out on
a bunch of tours the largest tour we
ever did was back
in 2014 we did a hundred cities over the
course of 10 months in 8 different
countries 119 different events and
during that process it was a different
vehicle to communicate our message of
simple living and in fact you can see
that much of that tour in our new
documentary which is called minimalism
it's on Netflix now for those of you who
are just tuning in it's also everywhere
else you can find all the details to
that and watch the trailer share the
trailer as well at minimalism film.com
and what we learned is that over time
there were all these different vehicles
to share our message of simple living
with other people again not in the in
any way trying to convert anyone or
convince anyone that minimalism is the
path you must follow it's a path that
can lead to a more fulfilling life a
more meaningful life and that really
starts with the stuff by letting go of
the excess stuff but the real purpose of
minimalism has to do with the benefits
we experience once we're on the other
side of decluttering and so over the
last six years we've found these
different vehicles whether it's our blog
or our books we've written three books
together middle Muslim of a meaningful
life the memoir which is called
everything that remains that's my
favorite thing I've ever created and
also we have an essay collection called
essential and it's 12 different chapters
on 12 different topics of living a more
intentional life everything from
minimalism and stuff to finances and
relationships and decluttering and
mindfulness and success and everything
in between and and those are those are
just some of the vehicles we've used but
last year we started a podcast so we
have a minimalist podcast now and many
of you are subscribers to that we also
have social media as a vehicle now why
are all these vehicles important I think
they're important because different
people find value in different vehicles
and it's also important to note that we
didn't start out on and try to tackle
all of these vehicles at once I think we
would have failed we started out with a
blog with a website and we started
writing essays we spent that first year
doing that and then eventually that we
had so many people asking when are you
gonna write a book when are you gonna
write a book that eventually we did
write a book and from there we started
using social media more regularly
because people finally found value in
that because we also realize that you
know what of
books that are sold a fewer than 10% of
people make it past the first chapter of
a book they buy so I could sell you a
hundred thousand copies of a book and
while that sounds really impressive only
ten or yeah only 10% of those people
10,000 people are gonna even make it
past the first chapter even a smaller
percentage you're gonna make it to the
end of the book so even if you write a
really compelling book and sell a bunch
of copies it's not going to reach nearly
as many people as maybe a TEDx talk
would or a video on YouTube or Facebook
and so the question I ask whenever we
use a new vehicle to create into share
value with other people is that question
is does this add value and what I mean
by that is does a serve a purpose or a
bring people joy in any way and so even
if it's a tweet if it's a funny joke
that I want to tweet or something I
think is a funny joke if I want to tweet
that then then I'm gonna ask before I
send it is this going to serve the
greater good is this going to add value
to someone's life and so we found these
different vehicles along the way and and
back back in 20 the end of 2013 so three
years ago now about half the life of the
minimalists so far we partnered up with
a very talented director named Matt dia
Vella he's from New York City and he has
done a bunch of really amazing
commercial work a very talented visual
genius but hadn't done a feature-length
film yet and he had wanted to do
something meaningful and with his
creative skills and talents and so he
decided you know what if I can partner
up with these guys after we talked him
into it basically I can create something
meaningful and so three years ago we
started working on a documentary and we
did that because we didn't want this
journey to continue to just be the Josh
and Ryan show it's great that we have a
message that we're able to communicate
with people but and they're able to find
value in it but let's show people there
are other lifestyles out there as well
so with the documentary we went out
there and we we interviewed minimalist
families and minimalist architects and
minimalist entrepreneurs and travelers
and tiny house enthusiasts and so
Associate wait so economists
and neuropsychology Errol psychologists
and neuroscientists and we found that
they're basically all of these different
all of these different views on living a
more intentional life we wanted to meld
those together to show people that
minimalism isn't this radical lifestyle
it is a practical lifestyle and quite
often people hear this word minimalism
and they think radical right they think
stark white walls and they think owning
no possessions and minimalism can
certainly do that for you if that's what
you prefer in fact one of the guys in
the film was a good friend of mine his
name's Colin Wright and he owns I think
52 things in the entire world everything
he owns fits in his backpack and while I
find that to be admirably it's not the
same life that I want to emulate and so
that was one one prescription for
minimalism or one way that minimalism
could help you life now he does that
because he likes traveling to new
countries and he travels all the time
he's a full time traveler and so him
owning a a a kitchen table is actually
getting in the way of travel and so I
saw the other side of things too with
people like Leo and Eva Bob Alta Leo's
in the documentary he has six kids he
and his wife Eva have six kids and their
whole minimalist family and then we have
people in the suburbs we have people in
the city we have people in tiny houses
we have people who are living the lives
that are appropriate to their life we
also backed it up with with much of the
the science and social science behind
the the benefits of minimalism and so
this documentary was another vehicle to
communicate that right and and so will
we use this vehicle in the future will
we create other documentaries yeah
probably
what would that will look like will be a
feature-length film will it be a TV show
will it be video essays will it be live
Q&A sessions more of these online in the
future yes probably to all of those the
key is am i excited about working on
this project and
and am I willing to put in the drudgery
to make it happen and is that going to
be a video thing is it going to be
another book is it going to be it is
going to be a different type of vehicle
a different type of creation and my
answer is I don't know yet exactly what
it looks like we have some ideas that
Ryan and I are throwing around in fact
next year in 2017 we want to hit the
road
with six simple ideas in front of some
more some small crowds because we've
we've been fortunate enough to garner a
large large audience and have some
fairly large crowds at our events but
once we're ready with some of these
ideas we're gonna hit the road and bring
them to some small crowds and try to
work them out in front of in front of an
audience before we film them or write
them or or or do whatever we're going to
do with these new ideas so that's that's
my short answer are we going to are we
gonna start a we're gonna do another
film in the future yeah maybe but if I
say yes to that that means I have to say
no to everything else so that I can
create the best thing possible and so
stay tuned if you're not on our mailing
list already our email list you'll know
about any tour dates we do or any new
creations we put out there you can just
go to the minimalists com enter your
email there and we'll never ever send
you spam because spam is disgusting
Sean do we have another question yeah so
asking about veganism well let's just
expand out a little bit on that let's
just talk about diet in general my diet
is over 90% plant-based and I think
that's important because many of these
lifestyles we tend to think of as binary
so you take minimalism as a lifestyle
it's not about owning nothing it's about
owning what's appropriate for my life
and I think you can extrapolate that and
transpose it on to this idea of diet as
well whether that's veganism or
vegetarianism or whatever you won't want
to call it most of my my diet is
plant-based although this year I just
started incorporating red meat back into
my life because I've had a significant
number of health issues you can go back
and listen to episode number three
of our podcast it's a episode call it a
way and you can check that out at the
minimalists comm slash podcast let's
talk about some of my health issues one
of the things I found out is I am anemic
and so I don't have a taste for red meat
at all but I did start incorporating
meat as medicine back into my life and
the good news is I'm no longer anemic
which is which is great for me but it's
also helping me refocus on on other
aspects of my life as well right and so
I should say other aspects of my diet as
well I probably have the most pristine
diet of anyone that I know and it's
because I've faced a lot of health
issues over the years throughout my late
20s I was on a long round of antibiotics
and it really killed my gut microbiome
and so I'm working on repopulating that
that I'm working with actually a team of
a couple doctors and a consultant and a
food scientist and my partner Becca
who's over here on the other side of the
room she is a registered dietician and
the best cook that I know by the way if
you want some great recipes you can
check out her website it's minimal
wellness.com and I think a hundred
percent of her recipes are gluten free
too so I my diet the cornerstones of my
diet are actually what are the things
that I avoid most so I avoid processed
foods including sugar I mean sugar is a
processed food so but let's just make
that a separate category I avoid sugar
and then I I tend to avoid gluten and
and I have a relatively low carbohydrate
diet relative to the standard American
diet but it's certainly not not a at
what one would call a ketogenic diet I
don't I'm not below you know a hundred
grams of carbs a day but I still have a
relatively low a carb diet but I'm
eating real foods and I think that's the
that's the key to a healthy diet for me
is am i eating a plant primarily
plant-based diet relatively balanced
diet and it is is essentially everything
that I put into my body a real food and
so if you want to read more about my
specific diet you can just go to the
minimalists com a slash diet and you can
see exactly what I eat and how I eat it
what's the next question it's demanding
okay so we're talking about holidays
family members who get offended that
they don't want to participate in the
the holiday gift exchange well a few
things we've gone through this this year
personally Becca's smiling right now so
we have we have a three-year-old Ella
you can follow on Twitter at a tell off
sandwich she says a lot of hilarious
things but let's see here so so Becca's
family does a sort of white elephant
gift exchange at Christmastime and for
whatever reason
Becca decided to opt out and said you
know I've already got everything that I
need but let me optela into this great
gift exchange and and every one of her
family is like no we everyone wants to
buy Ella a gift this year right because
we all want to give and and we've been
told this is so it's part of our culture
we've been indoctrinated to believe that
gift-giving is what it's a love language
I think that's like saying Pig Latin is
a Romance language the truth is that
gift-giving in its most literal sense is
not a love language what we mean by
gift-giving is a love language we mean
contribution is a love language and so
quite often we confuse giving a physical
shiny object look I got you this shiny
thing right here this shows you how much
I love you right
no it shouldn't show you how much I love
you my daily actions how I how I behave
everyday toward you shows you how much I
care how much I love you yet in our
culture we've gotten confused and we
think that because I give you something
that shows how much I love you and by
the way now I have this expectation it's
called obligatory gift-giving right and
I think that giving gifts on the
holidays are actually one of the worst
times to to give a gift because
everyone's expecting again Hey
December 25th I got you this widget what
widget did you get from me let's compare
and contrast so I can see how much you
cared about me relative to how much I
care about you what a terrible way to
celebrate a holiday right especially for
these so-called Hallmark holidays right
Valentine's Day is I think probably the
most grotesque example here I bought you
some shiny rocks that someone may have
lost a limb for and to show you that I
care about you and now you give me
whatever thing that shows me you care
about me I prefer so let's talk about
gift-giving in general I prefer two
things first off are three things really
first off I prefer to gift experiences
over stuff and so I think during the
holidays instead of it saying I don't
want to participate in your stupid
gift-giving process I think it's silly
well I just kind of turn everyone off
and make everyone upset why you don't
want to do that for the holiday that's
not your outcome right your outcome is
yes I want to enjoy the holidays with
you how can you do that one set of
physical gifts let's replace the gifts
with experiences and so find experiences
that will resonate with you and if you
have kids especially a part of that
experience might mean we had someone
call into our podcast and talk about
this recently I think part of that
experience is maybe you have to also buy
a babysitter so the parents can go out
and have a good experience on their own
right maybe it's concert tickets or a
movie or just a night out by themselves
or maybe it's an experience for the
whole family recently Beck's and I we
took Ella to go Christmas tree hunting
you can actually go back and listen to
our holiday episode on the podcast it
was episode number 41 and I talked about
that experience it was quite the
challenging experience because we almost
died Christmas tree hunting but it makes
it much more memorable experience
doesn't it but even if even if we
wouldn't have been in any danger we've
we've done it's this this is the second
year in a row we've gone out Christmas
tree hunting and that's an experience
that for $5.00 you go buy a Christmas
tree permit and you just go cut you
spend the afternoon hunting hunting a
Christmas tree finding going out finding
one in areas that you're allowed to find
one and a lot of states do this
not just out in Montana or Minnesota
places like that but a lot of states
will allow you to do this and you find a
Christmas tree and you make an
experience out of that there are a bunch
of other experiences so ask yourself
what experiences do you find meaningful
what experience would you find
meaningful would your family find
meaningful and maybe encourage them to
give those to you and then also you want
to lead by example obviously give those
experiences to them right and so I think
now is a great time to start to shift
the paradigm paradigm now I say start to
shift right because when is the best
time to talk about Christmas gifts it's
February you're already way way way too
late and so you're going to have to
concede to some of the normal traditions
and expectations because by definition
traditions are not very flexible but you
can implement new traditions next year
and you can start that now you can start
to plant the seeds for next year right
now and make a little bit of room this
year so that next year your holiday
season is much more meaningful and by
the way this more this holiday will be
more meaningful by implementing some
subtle changes in your tradition this
year so give some experiences if you
need to give a physical item some of
those experiences you can gift up baby
you can you can box up and hand into a
because someone wants that physical gift
and the especially but with kids Ella
loves unwrapping things and so even if
we're going to go do something like
we're gonna take her to to Florida this
the spring and we'll give that to her
for Christmas but we're boxing that up
and so it's a raft experience so to
speak and I find even that the
experience of unwrapping is in and of
itself another experience that they get
to enjoy for her birthday this year I
wrapped up a pineapple and gave it to
her and also blew up a bunch of balloons
so she came downstairs and there were
balloons everywhere and she just loves
balloons and so again another experience
and that you wouldn't think of as as a
traditional gift-giving experience but
what else if you're going absolutely
give give gifts the physical gifts if
you need to why not gift consumables
right a nice bottle of wine or a really
great bag of coffee from one of your
favorite Coffee Roasters a few of my
favorites are dog
coffee and in heart coffee roasters and
there are a bunch of others out there
too you can go to our Instagram page at
the minimalists and see some of our
favorite minimalist city finds whenever
we go to a new city we talk about some
of our favorite coffees you can also
check out our coffee house in st.
Petersburg Florida
the minimalist calm slash coffee house
you can see a photo tour of that so gift
a bag of coffee a really great bag
coffee or bottle of wine or what are
other consumables that you can share an
experience with someone else think about
that and you can give a physical item
that once it's done it's done and I
think that's pretty nice and the last
thing I'll tell you about gift-giving is
obligatory gifts I have big I have a
void bligg Ettore gift giving obligatory
gift giving whenever I can what does
that mean so I already talked about
December 25th or or well here's it's
today's December 25th you have to give
me a gift or today is February 14th you
have to give me some sort of gift right
okay if you want to do that that's fine
but how about today is March 8th why'd
you give me this gift well because I
care about you now I don't think the
gift-giving equals love but I do think
that you'll find value in this thing and
because I care about you I want you to
find value in the things I give you why
am I going to wait until December 25th
to give you that thing when I can give
you this thing on March 3rd or November
11th or whenever I want to show you I
care about you every day I don't want to
wait until 6 or 7 days throughout the
year to show you that I care so if I
think you'll find value in something
whether it's a physical good or an
experience let's not wait until the
holiday let me show you I care about you
right now and let me show you I care
about you every single day Sean what's
our next question so the question is
about having tools necessary to do a
task and in
context specifically it has to do with
education so teachers or students who
need to have a lot of books or a lot of
paperwork or and the teachers case my
former spouse she's an eighth grade
teacher and she had just so many
accoutrements that she needed to adorn
her classroom with or at least a sheen
to adorn her classroom list so a couple
answers that I'll have here one is
minimalism is not about deprivation and
so as a minimalist everything I own
serves a purpose or brings me joy and
everything else I get out of the way so
we have to be honest about the things
that we have and so many of these things
if they're tools they actually serve a
purpose in your life and so you can be a
minimalist and still have a lot of tools
to do the tasks you need to do now the
way to determine whether or not those
tools actually add value to your life is
through temporary deprivation sometimes
so again minimalism is not about
temporary
it's not about deprivation but it can be
about temporary deprivation to determine
whether or not these things are adding
value to your life
and so for me I will quite often do
experiments with different bits of
technology so whether it's my phone I
got rid of my phone for 60 days I wrote
about that over at the minimalists comm
and by letting go of that I learned that
I could bring it back into my life more
deliberately it was adding value to my
life in a long term I was actually
depriving myself of that thing I didn't
want to do that at all right I wanted I
wanted to have the thing as a tool but I
didn't want to be a slave to the tool
and so by removing it from my life I
brought it back in and I started using
it differently and so what if you met
now is actually a really good time if
you're a teacher and you're taking a
break from those tools summers
especially a great time if you have to
tear down your classroom and all that
other stuff or if you're a student as
well if you remove those things
temporarily from your life put them in a
basement or a closet or the trunk of
your car or whatever for a temporary
period of time and then realize what did
add value and what you just thought was
adding value to your life and and I
think I think that's important because
quite often we mistake perceived value
for real value and it's one of the most
common mistakes and the other thing that
we we mistake we mistake just in case
items
for value-adding items so we often hold
on to many of these these are Kuchar
mints that we have for classrooms or
studying or whatever I was talking to
Ryan about this the other day your for a
long time when he was going through his
packing party
he still had these old calculate he's a
huge fan of math and it was really in
the mathematics but he had always
calculus textbooks and notes and he
couldn't even decipher most of the the
notes that he have he was holding on to
them just in case he needed them someday
and some non-existent hypothetical
future and I've learned that just in
case of the three most dangerous words
in our English language and we have to
be willing to let go of things we're
holding on to just in case and quite
often we can figure out what we're
holding on to just in case by
temporarily depriving ourselves of those
things and then bringing them back in
but using them differently when we do I
went without home internet for a very
long time and that was a very powerful
experience one of the most productive
times in my life it allowed me to write
three books during the years I had no
home Internet service all right anyway
well what else have I deprived myself of
the phone already mentioned I went
without oh television for a very very
long time about nine years without
television and I still don't have like
what would be considered traditional TV
but Backson I do enjoy once or twice a
week watching a film or a really good TV
show although I found that I'm just not
as entertained anymore once I've removed
that pacifier from my life for a very
long time there are very few things that
I'm like eager to watch but then the
things I am eager watching last night we
we finished the ninth episode of
Westworld which is such a good TV show
and if you haven't seen it yet and you
have an opportunity to see it I would
encourage you to see it because it spurs
some really great conversations about
consciousness and immorality and
artificial intelligence and there's so
many great just well written lines and
that thing - we will pause it and rewind
lines and and and watch it and so I
found a way to bring that back into my
life in a much much more deliberate way
so I'm using those tools much more
deliberately than I would have if I were
just to continue to coast on on that
pacifier mode
that also means that I constantly need
to reevaluate and keep asking this
question does this add value to my life
and if I'm honest with myself I can
temporarily deprive myself and and let
go of something for a period of time and
then bring it back in in a much more
intentional fashion and so try that with
many of the things also I will tell you
I think physical clutter is much more
problematic than digital clutter it
doesn't mean the digital clutter is not
a problem in fact Ryan and I did an
entire episode on technology of our
podcast so go to episode number 2 of the
minimalist podcast it's an entire
episode about technology but I will tell
you this I used to own 2,000 books 2,000
books now some of those I had actually
read but let's be honest most of them I
I I bought with the intention of reading
someday but it was just like a
just-in-case item you go to the book
store and you buy 5 6 7 8 books and
you're like oh my god like I can't read
that fast even right I'm lucky if I read
well I'm lucky if I get past page 50 in
a book if I get past page 50 it tends to
be a masterpiece because I refuse to
waste my time on getting to the end of a
book but I had this huge bookshelf on my
wall huge bookshelf with 2,000 books and
I realized it was part of my identity I
had those because it made me look smart
and when people came over I'd say oh
yeah I've got this book in this book and
all you've actually read Infinite Jest
yeah okay but but the truth is that the
value isn't in the artifact itself the
value is in the experience of of the
bulk of reading the book and then by
letting go of those books I could add
value to other people's lives because
someone else could then experience those
words as well so I now have a much
smaller physical book collection it's a
a well curated book collection maybe a
60 70 books total and and those are
books I tend to go back and reference
they're books I've really enjoyed that I
like to share with other people and the
new books I bring in occasion I'll have
a physical book where for the most part
I use ebooks and so I don't know what
your prefered eReader is mine happens to
be a Kindle I and
fact I will Alfa nanite I'll read the
backs we were reading last night before
we went to bed and most of the time
that's just with that is just with the
the the Kindle that I have there at my
bedside right and so I found that books
were especially proud and problematic
for me when I went through this
experience of moving and I had to move
2,000 books and you know when you pull
the books off the shelf they're really
light when you put them in a box one at
a time but you fill up a huge box of
books and it's pretty damn heavy and so
I threw my back out moving a box of a
huge box of books and so when people
tell me that while digital clutter is
just as problematic as physical clutter
I will tell them to try to move 2,000
physical books and then try to move
2,000 books on their Kindle and you tell
me which is more difficult that's not to
say that we don't need to organize
things digitally I think it's important
to do that but I think the biggest
problem is the external color that we
experience I think our physical clutter
is a physical manifestation of what's
going on inside us and so by clearing
the external clutter we're able to start
dealing with the internal clutter which
ultimately helps us deal with the
eternal clutter that we're all facing
the existential clutter that we're all
facing until next week well oh and by
the way if you have a bunch of papers
scan them have a scanning party go to
the minimalists com scanning see the
scanner that I use personally get rid of
all your extra photos and paperwork and
actually store them digitally so that
you have a backup if anything were to
happen to them and you can do the same
with your text books as well if you
really feel like I need to hold on to
this text book you can send that off to
someone there's a company called one
dollar scan comm and you can you can
send your stuff off to them they'll scan
it for you and then they'll incinerate
the the paperwork you've sent them
they'll deal with the clutter for you
what's next shot
- ready versus okay yeah so let's talk
about living in general so questions
about tiny houses and questions about
renting versus buying or just living
situations so one of the segments in our
documentary which for those of you just
tuning in it's now available on Netflix
it's called minimalism a documentary
about the important things one of the
things we did was we wanted to show
various lifestyles in terms of home life
right and so we have folks from the tiny
house movement which I really admire but
I'm not really into tiny house living I
don't want to live in a tiny home myself
especially with a family I think would
be prohibitive but even if I was by
myself I I would find it more appealing
I don't find it as appealing I enjoy
having more space not large amounts of
space but an appropriate amount of space
in fact we interviewed an architect in
our documentary his name's Frank
and he kept using this word that just
it's stuck with me and in fact I think
it is the perfect word of the perfect
metaphor for minimalism
he's a minimal starchitect he talks
about when he builds a house for someone
he doesn't ask them do you want a living
room or do you want a dining room or do
you want three bedrooms or do you want
whatever were an entertainment room
because ultimately we tend to say yes do
I want two dining room oh I think I'm
supposed to have a dining room so yes
and said he asks you how do you live
your life and he has people expand on
that question how am I gonna live my
life and then he builds a house around
that life instead of trying to cram a
life into the house and so I think
that's what's important so whether
you're living in a tiny house the
question is is that appropriate for you
or are you living in a micro apartment
so in in the documentary most of you saw
Graham Hill who has this 420 square foot
apartment and it is an amazing apartment
it sleeps seven I believe it has a home
theater and it has a full kitchen it has
a dining room table that seats twelve it
has a home office with a stand-up desk
as a full bathroom with a shower but
it's a it's 400
20 square feet in the middle of
Manhattan and you're like house is
possible well it's a modular apartment
it's much more functional than most
2,000 square foot apartments we also had
a couple in there
David Freelander and and his wife
Jacqueline and they had you know 520 560
square foot micro apartment in Brooklyn
and what they had learned through a lot
of study is that we use about 40% of our
homes on a monthly basis that means 60%
of our homes in America go go unused and
the average house being built last year
is over 4,000 square feet and in
addition to that we have 2.2 billion
square feet of storage space so we're
building houses that still aren't big
enough to hold all of our crap that is
not a housing problem that is a stuff
problem right and the cool thing about
finding a space that is appropriate for
you I know it so in some ways forces you
to get rid of the excess stuff because
you're not gonna have a bunch of storage
space I remember when I first moved to
to Missoula Montana we started a
publishing company called asymmetrical
press it was me and Ryan and our friend
Colin we were looking for houses to rent
and we found a house that would have
been perfect
but it had a ton of storage space and I
know for some people that is a selling
point but for me it said no it made me
say no I paying for a bunch of wasted
space I don't want that there was these
huge walk-in closets so what do I need a
walk-in closet for now some people that
may be appropriate for their life
generally it's probably not the average
American household has 300,000 items in
it and for most of us that's because
we've crammed a life into the house
we've been given instead of trying to
build a home or fit a home around the
lifestyle that we want so if you want to
see a tour of Beck's
in my minimalist home you can go to the
minimalists comm slash Milburn that's my
last name
and you can see Ryan and his partner
Mariah they live in a loft and in
Missoula
and you can find that at the minimalists
comm / Nicodemus now what I'll tell you
this is my life has changed over the
years
right so the things that when I first
embraced minimalism the things that
added value to my life at age 28 aren't
the same things that I value to my life
at age 35 and vice versa is true that my
life has changed so I bring new things
into my life that add value now and so
I'm constantly asking that question does
this add value to my life and if not I
have to be willing to let go so that I
can focus on only that's what which is
important and have the excess it's sort
of clear the path toward toward living
my best life and being my best self and
so I'm constantly aspiring to be you
know I'm 35 now I'm aspiring to be my 36
year old self I want to be the best
version of myself and and part of that
includes the the clutter that I bring
into my living space so you can see a
bunch of different living perspectives
including Joshua and Kim Becker and
there are two kids they live in a house
in the suburbs and and that life is of
that house is appropriate for their
lifestyle I don't think there's a one
size fits all I think it'd be great if
there were because it'd be easy if I get
to hand you your list of here's the
thousand items you're supposed to own
and here's the square footage you're
supposed to have to be happy and for
each new kid that you bring on board
you're supposed to have this many items
and this many additional square feet it
just doesn't work that way because your
life is different from mine and so the
things that add value to your life may
not add value to my life and so we have
to keep asking that question what's next
yeah yeah so so how do you talk about
minimalism and then how do you get
started with minim
and I'm gonna make a third question
there how do you get other people on
board with minimalism as well and I
think these all three flow together
really nicely so the first way you
explain minimalism when someone asked me
well what is minimalism in fact I was
just that uh Beck's brother just got
married and someone asked me about
minimalism at the wedding reception and
when someone asked me about minimalism I
will answer their question with another
question I will say how might your life
be better with less I'll just pause and
let them think about that for a moment
now I'm not positing that question to
sound pious but I want to get people to
think about what minimalism is because
quite often we just think of getting rid
of all of our stuff or we think about
minimalist architecture or minimalist
literature minimalist artwork minimalist
music and and those are all appropriate
associations when you think about
minimalism but but really what we want
to talk about is minimalism as a life
style and so I'll ask this question how
might your life be better with less and
so when you're talking about how do I
get started with minimalism that's also
how you get started with minimalism you
ask yourself that question how my life
be better with less now why I asked that
question in the first place well we want
to ask that question because we want to
identify what the benefits of minimalism
are we all understand the how-to side of
things right you know how to declutter
your closet you'll never see me and Ryan
right the four hundred and thirteen tips
on how to remove the clutter from your
kitchen cabinets because everyone knows
the hell to side of things at least for
the most part now somehow two little
tips and tricks those can be helpful and
so don't get me wrong I think the how-to
can be beneficial but it's much more
beneficial once you understand the much
more powerful why - so how might your
life be better with less is the why -
it's the purpose behind minimalism for
me it started off with with regaining
control of my finances how my life be
better with less well I made really good
money in the corporate world back in my
corporate days I was a director of
operations for a hundred and fifty
retail stores and while that might sound
impressive it wasn't very fulfilling in
fact instead of happiness and
contentment that career
of working 70 80 hours a week it brought
me a lot of stress and anxiety in debt
and discontent and as even more debt
debt was a big feature of my life back
then in fact I had six figures worth of
debt if you count my mortgage I had half
a million dollars worth of debt so I
made really good money but I spent even
better money and so my life my financial
life was out of control and was the
biggest anchor of my life and I could
tell you if you don't have financial
freedom you're gonna feel anchors
everywhere else in your life you're
gonna be tied to a particular lifestyle
and for me I wanted to get out of debt
and so regaining control of the way I
was spending my money minimalism allowed
me to do that but then they I started
uncovering all these other benefits as
well as I started simplifying my life
what else happened well as I simplified
I started regaining control of my health
and it turns out I've had forsaken my
health for most of my adult life at one
point I weighed 80 pounds more than I
weigh now but I also forced took the
people closest to me so my relationships
were in shambles because most of my
relationships were birthed out of
proximity or convenience and spending
90% of my time with people on the
periphery the tertiary tier of
relationships that the co-workers the
networking buddies the executives the
people who I thought had influence and
and and because of that the people I
said I really cared about and loved I
said I'll well understand I'll spend
more time with them one day well I
needed to say instead of saying one day
I needed to say today is day one right
flip that around and say now as when I
need to prioritize those relationships
and minimalism allowed me to do that and
start focusing on what was important to
me the relationships that were important
to me also what other benefits might you
experience by letting go how else might
your life be better with less well for
some people it's like I really want to
focus on I've always wanted to start
yoga or I wanted to to focus on this
passion project how I've always want to
write a novel or write this book or
start a blog or I've wanted to travel my
whole life these are all great benefits
if that's really what you want to do and
there's something in the way perhaps
minimalism is a really good first step
toward pursuing that value in your life
it's going to help you identify what
your value
are in fact Ryan and I wrote about these
five values that we uncovered in our
first book called minimalism live a
meaningful life we once we got the
excess stuff out of the way we said okay
what's most important to us because it
was strange I I was ostensibly
successful but I didn't actually know
what was important to me and so I was
successful a narrow sense like I had a
prestigious job title and I supposedly
made a good amount of money but I wasn't
fulfilled by that lifestyle and so how
do you reach fulfilment how do you reach
a meaningful life it's not by pursuing
happiness in fact I think happiness is
often the problem of of our culture the
constant pursuit of happiness we confuse
happiness with ephemeral pleasure with
ephemeral indulgences we say well I'm
going to be happy if I get this thing
temporary pleasure is not the same thing
as long-lasting happiness I think
happiness has much more to do with
living a meaningful life it's a
byproduct of living a meaningful life
and what that means is aligning your
short-term daily actions with what your
long-term values are and so the values
the Ryan and I uncut Ryan and I
uncovered were health relationships
passion or what you might call
creativity and then growth and
contribution and focusing on those
things allows me to live a much more
meaningful life and as a result be
happier yes I am much happier at age 35
than I was at age 27 but again I don't
think happiness is the point I think
living a more meaningful life is the
point and happiness is a beautiful
byproduct of that so think now the
question that just means well how do I
get others on board how do I force
minimal minimalism ones of my spouse my
sister my mother my brother my child you
don't I say how do you force him to play
ice hockey I'd be a little weird
wouldn't it if someone was asking me
that question I'm like well why would
you want to force someone to play an ice
hockey right well here's the problem
though or the paradox I should say with
minimalism it is much easier if you have
other people in your life on board and
so I think some ways to do that are to
express the benefits to them so when
you're asking the question how am I your
life you'd better with less you also
want to show them
your life might be better with less
right now you want to show them how your
life is better with less now for me I
didn't jump up and say look at me I'm
becoming a minimalist and you need to to
instead people at work started saying
you're less stressed or you're happier
or you're calmer or what the hell is
going on with you you've totally changed
and that opened up the door for me to
talk about minimalism by way of the
benefits I was experiencing now why
would why did they care because they
cared about the benefits they didn't
care about decluttering their closet if
you don't know why your declutter in
your closet it'll just be cluttered
again a month from now two months from
now a week from now whatever but if you
know the why that gives you the momentum
you need to keep going even when times
are difficult because quite often we
confuse excitement for long lasting
results
we'll get excited about an idea I really
wanted to clean up and declutter my home
but if you don't know why you're doing
it you're gonna end up exactly back
where it where you were but if you
understand viscerally understand the
purpose emotionally understand the
purpose of letting go you'll be able to
keep going now how else do we get
started I'll give you a few tips one is
play the thirty-day minimalism game you
can find the details to that also tens
of thousands of other people who have
been playing it by searching the hashtag
over on Instagram or Twitter its hashtag
mins game mi NS game it's good at the
minimalists calm a slash game here's how
it works the beginning of a new month
you partner up with someone friend a
family member a co-worker and enemy
whomever someone you decide to get rid
of some stuff with and now you bet
whatever you want you bet a dollar a
nice meal a trip somewhere bet whatever
you want to bet bragging rights and then
at the beginning of the month you decide
we're gonna get rid of some stuff it
starts out really easy because the first
day of the month you each get rid of one
item day two two items day three three
items starts to pick up you start to get
that momentum you need and and it fuels
the fire with some friendly competition
I don't know about you but I think
decluttering is kind of boring for those
of you who think decluttering is awesome
I applaud you good for you Wow
I don't think decluttering is exciting
so if you think it's boring like I do
then you're gonna make it a little more
fun with some friendly competition and
so partner up with someone start out
simple but it gets more difficult as a
month progresses right because day 15
you're getting rid of 15 items day 16 16
items oh my good what 17 items we're
gonna get rid of tomorrow day 20 it's
even more difficult day 25 now whoever
goes the longest throughout the month
wins if you both make it to the end of
the month you've both won because you've
both gotten rid of about 500 items and
that's a really good start and we've had
many people who continue to play beyond
the 30 days or they'll even start over
on day 31 or maybe you just go to day 40
it's 40 items whatever you want to do
you continue to put a dent in that now
you ask about what are the rules there's
a hangar account there's a paperclip
count whatever you want to count counts
be honest with yourself establish the
same rules together it's flexible the
purpose is to get that momentum I find
that many people who start out on this
journey they can't wait to get way past
500 items because once you get that
momentum letting go gets easier by the
day the more you do it the freer and
happier and lighter you feel and the
more stuff you want to throw overboard
and then as you do that other people
will jump on board in our house week we
have a donation box we console have Ella
who wants to donate everything now even
if she doesn't like her dinner that
evening she'll try to donate it which is
which is quite comical but I think we're
starting to establish a habit early
realizing that if I let go of some of
these things you know what other people
can find value in it just because
something doesn't add value to my life
doesn't mean it won't add value to
someone else's life and so my
willingness to let go is also my
willingness to add value to other
people's lives a few other rules that
might help you along the way
I'm gonna recommend the 9090 rule you
can find that at our website the
minimalists comm slash 90 and how that
works is have I used this item in the
last 90 days am I going to use it in the
next 90 days if not I give myself
permission to let go of it
that typically accounts for seasonality
because I go back 90 days now it's it's
going to be summertime and if I go back
for 90 days it's gonna be spring time
and so you
you're gonna for the most part cover all
seasons with that and if not I'm willing
to let go of it donate it sell it I tend
to try to sell things that are that are
greater than $250 if not I try to donate
the thing another rule that might help
you out the 20/20 rule we also call this
the just-in-case rule now I realized
that many of the things I was holding on
to thousands of items if not tens of
thousands of items I was holding on to
just in case but I realized that many of
those items that I was holding on to
just in case I could replace for less
than $20 in less than 20 minutes from
wherever I am that rule was held up for
me and I've only had to use it five
times in the last five years and and
since we came up with that rule and the
cool thing about that is it's given me
permission to let go of tens of
thousands of items just in case items
because I know I'm not actually gonna
have to replace them and the five times
I've had to use it
that means I've spent what a hundred
bucks in five years it's not like you're
going out replacing all these just in
case items every single day no you
barely ever have to use that and the
rules worked 100% of the time for me my
guess is it probably works 99% of the
time I'm sure there's an exception that
proves the rule one last rule or
actually it's a theory I call it the the
ten ten material possessions theory it
comes from a book called spent and the
way that works is you take a piece of
paper on the front of that piece of
paper you look at the last decade and
you look at your 10 most expensive
purchases over the last decade and you
flip the piece of paper over and you
write down the 10 most meaningful
experiences over the last decade and
then you will just be shocked when you
compare the two lists and you find out
that probably not a single item on there
corresponds or maybe one item
corresponds to and what that let that
what that helped me realize is that you
know what there are so many things I've
brought into my life because I thought
it was gonna argument my life experience
but it wasn't actually augmenting my
life experience in fact many times it
was just getting in the way of my most
meaningful experiences and life and so
before I tuned out here we're at the
hour mark I want to remind those of you
who are just tuning in our documentary
is finally available
on Netflix it's called minimalism a
documentary about the important things
and thank you so much to everyone who is
rated it so far is really close to five
stars if you find value in film and only
if you find value in the film if you'd
be willing to leave it a five star
rating and a review we'd greatly
appreciate it
whether you sold on Netflix or if it's
not available on Netflix wherever you
are you can find on itunes google play
amazon in most countries or worldwide on
vimeo the cool thing about the Vimeo
link by the way is it has six hours of
bonus content that is exclusive to Vimeo
so you can dive deeper into the
interviews you can find those even if
you if you watch the film on Netflix or
any other platform you can get just the
bonus content over at Vimeo as well you
can find links to all that stuff over at
minimalism film comm you can interact
with us over on social media wherever
you find us we're at the minimalists
pretty much everywhere and if you leave
here today with just one message I hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for your time y'all i'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'd
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tell your team
[Music]
you
[Music]